[Music]
breathe in
and breathe out
imagine flickering a flame
you must slow down your heartbeat
breathe in
breathe from down here
breathe out slowly
[Applause]
walk your heart beat as fast sorry try
to focus okay are you there
and breathe out let your mind go clear
[Music]
why do you come to us
I just want to keep my family safe
[Music]
treat them as our brothers and sisters
teach them our ways
far sport
if you want to live here
you have to ride
let's do it
Just Breathe
breathe
[Music]
[Applause]
Outcast that's all they see
I see
[Music]
I'm a warrior like you I'm supposed to
fight
protect the people
[Music]
[Applause]
they're done
[Music]
[Applause]
Avatar the way of water experience it in
3D
only in theaters December 16th
[Music]